this is what I've always dreamed of man
when I was a kid look I'm doing it like
a Princess Bride
Chuck Ison show me that's right yeah
ie the ba ba ba guess what we do on this
show figure out what's in the box and we
figure that out with keen detection
skills in one of these we open the box
and then we pull the stuff out look at
the screen junkies get so much crap set
to amount of regular basis they asked us
to open a form and we don't have jobs
anymore so we were more than happy to do
it man so let's dive into this week's
box to find out what's in the box well
open sir we wait what is it beep item
it's a blade bill I know it is from this
Jedi Master lightsaber or saber laser
Dave might receive Jedi it is basically
you make your own yes you take see the
lights are okay so look there's a bunch
of different ones to build like I would
build this one because that's the one I
know from the movie I'm not very
imaginative that's not bad man although
when I play with a toy I just want to
open it and go I don't want to put it
together not necessarily it comes with
the standard one yeah for it free for
you yeah and then I build one and while
you're learning to use yours what your
Jedi mind tricks are building my and
then you come at me and I'm like hit
this Hyson what did you see the
commercial no but I just you know is
that in Jedi my minutes the language in
Star Wars right on the rounds I get
scope Jedi's not the language I know but
I'm just saying I was Revenge of the
language now man is that that's like how
they indicated in Star Wars like orders
but back back in the first Star Wars
that English words written on stuff but
now it's all about this now we own this
language Disney owns this language
Disney made up a whole new language
shall we open it yes let's do it
I'm gonna let you open this alright show
them how a boy opens his toys kill the
tape back up is to do this now pour
oh and look at that there's the
instruction sheet lots of these they
don't work is if you don't know how to
build it they will teach you oh yes I'm
I feel like a dad this is a dad job look
I'll get it out for you and that's it
and then they go and do you two like to
baby sabers bro or nice Savai'i that's a
movie I want to see
show me that stuff yeah little like like
a switchblade lightsaber it's like you
know and they're not yeah right here
yeah how you do this first my time oh no
you're not scared
Wow like they're little I'm like those
are little but then I'm like oh and I've
gutted myself by cutting you down you
know what I'm the director okay so
basically in the box there's lots and
lots of more pieces this is apparently
the Star Wars The Force awakens blade
builders so in a movie where they're
introducing a new lightsaber that we've
never seen before
I guess the off the ideas hey kids build
your own lightsaber like Luke Skywalker
he built his own lightsaber return to
the gym oh I see you have constructed a
new lightsaber speaking of we have the
Luke Scott I want to open it up in I
think that's the idea of opening
unboxing don't know we got us we got to
show each one this is Star Wars blade
builders Luke Skywalker lightsaber mmm
right here will open that chamois
Kuzon so we have that one
like I said oh sorry you're fun to play
with too because you make sound effects
like the dude from police academy and
colony that he's getting though I know
you don't have to be as good you just
have to be good enough you know me my
thing is good and I good that's for
other people look at this this is
alright so this is obviously this the
hammer the handle
but I need some twit if I had three of
these mothers look at that oh you might
you might have four give me your little
ones first yeah these are gonna look
badass right here no this doesn't go all
the way down oh come on
all right I'll run can eat it if I
showed up like this if he called up his
and I was like [ __ ] like you can fight
with a dude and give him hope where it's
like all blocked but then I go and
that's it right oh my goodness would be
great all right so here we have another
nerf soft bone blade Oh get out of here
man it's a nerf this is what I've always
dreamed of man this is a soft bone blade
Luke nerf one there we go like feel that
is that there you go ouch not bad right
played it hurts
ouch not really like don't get hit kids
but not enough to be like I never want
to play this [ __ ] again yeah it does
sort of ring your don't ever get your
dome rang know it hurts here we go all
right all right go
oh you're right Oh see that was hard but
it was our don't hit my head let's say
we don't but let's hit him hard don't
see how Barbican oh he awakened the
force look at that man look what's
inside what's inside the force glass
plastic which hurts and I know is your
dome I knew it
all right whoa just in kids oh and as
you do like with the real lightsaber
immediately touch the blade all right
all right come on
when I was a kid look I'm doing it like
a princess bride me when I was a kid
they had flashlights oh that you would
just basically had a long stick on it
that lit up pretend you have two sabers
okay I'm just wondering this these two
things they're saying what are they for
do you think they're for this like
Katehi wild me with his handle and then
I got just hiking yeah here's a preview
of the force awakens kids ready
you son of a bad either that or this one
turns into a light penis and he's like
this it's truly right in your mouth and
all her face
ooh what's this
the little plastic part it's probably
too extended all right so this goes oh
it snaps it oh I see it's a connector
joint there we go there you go it's a
snap joint and then you can go oh but I
don't want to have blue and red gay oh
snaps what isin got the laser under your
shoulder this is for the floor piece
what it doesn't piece for it's the
connector like this then people would
have like reason to be like these movies
have become ridiculous listen to me your
first world order skunk
I got me a light saber does have a sound
effect it doesn't fly what do you got
and then the wind alone blows you back
so I don't even get a chance no I'm just
spinning it at full speed time so you're
like a Jedi with a windmill come on
people I'm not sure this is pretty down
here let me try to attack you defend I
would just do this Oh could you imagine
if this was the fight scene in Star Wars
go ahead boys keep people behind me to
be amazing I could shoot that action
sequence one camera above ya poor dudes
just going like this all for ya like
someone's here yes
sons behind me and someone's over here
watch oh my goodness bun JJ if it's not
too late he choreographed a scene that
will ward very well I could be like the
little two-foot 10-inch stuntman any
attention no different sure sorry
alright look at this I think they made
this for you like I don't think children
would have its fun with this as you're
having with it
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] the force has awoken
brother Zhang Zhang so like how do we
compete Jesus dude right that's about
the only thing more than kylo Ren's
lightsaber that I think and look it
fires like a gun so the good news kids
is you got enough pieces here to build
yourself anything including this lovely
Jedi menorah celebrate the night that is
different than all other nights in the
Star Wars way they call it life day in
the Star Wars universe we all know what
it is Rosh Hashanah so the idea of this
is you build your own lightsaber let's
put it together
that's how I'm fighting alright this is
it this is the move nobody could get me
the only thing missing is if it went all
the way around me and I could just -
alright so this is like this is
manageable this is kind of badass and
look it also sends a message a few first
order this is practical if you saw
somebody turn this on like they just
have this thing without little things on
and then went like Chang and turned on
well that shouldn't go like that but
generally speaking you'd be like that's
pretty wicked and stuff this that is not
that's how you lose the store all right
kids
we did some building look at this you
show them yours
this is nuts wah-wah-wah no one will
touch me come on man that's that's the
ultimate lightsaber bow but you don't
even need somebody else to fight you
could fight yourself man versus himself
it's one of the three great stories work
cut my leg off no and it's the reverse
of empire cuz instead of a hand no foot
he's got to get a bionic foot look it
breaks into two and it's claws - like
Wolverines next big so you could giant
snitched as well very inventive thank
you thank you this was mine
try as I could oh you like something
that's very braces I just is it it's
very it's it's practical I'm not saying
I'm all for it but like this is good
design I'm not saying that about the
swastika saying that about flights today
very now like to be fair before it
belonged to the Nazis the swastika
belongs to somebody else's backwards and
it's still nice whatever but it meant
nice things but this is more practical
it's saying about anything else but
practicality look at this try attacking
me from any angle go ahead I'm just
doing this today No
denied denied third time it's over it's
over all right this is my ultimate
weapon I'm doing here this is a cross
for Jesus yes people of all faiths and
creeds can enjoy the blade building man
there's only one thing I would like to
do like sit like let's build a trident
by God no I'm saying like they have a
picture right here that looks pretty
damn close to try to it says one plus
two equals three well well done right
look at that yeah people say he's not
that bright for now
[Music]
Jason will be trying to build this I'm
gonna give you 20 seconds on the clock
and the lightsaber tried I'm shine here
we go oh there we go
getting close five seconds all right
that's that so I just need this corner
yeah but you got close look at that yeah
it's kind of there that's not bad you
know honestly I thought it'd be a lot
cooler than it was snip it there we go
none shall pass or I don't remember
Aquaman ever since but I think we need
smaller ones right we did three small
pieces I said look I think we can this
pretty down do this all night long
clearly one of us could do it all night
long but let's weigh in we unboxed Star
Wars blade builders you got a quick
review I think they're awesome I think
lots of fun they light up there's nerf
ones you can hit people with but not too
hard and did you see how it takes like
the mind of an idiot you keep them
occupied for a few minutes oh it's great
for when you got one of those
hyperactive kids you don't want to drug
them let's give them this and look in
creative creating all new shapes and
having good time even by himself that's
Star Wars 1 by yourself
[Music]
we're done unboxing man you just hung
out with me Kevin Smith
JC mule we found out what's in the box
what was in the box er hey we want to
thank the good folks at Hasbro for
giving us all this incredible lightsaber
action all phallic action all over this
table man fantastic anybody could have a
good time with this I'm gonna give us
that to my mother she's 70 but what if
she what is this is this a light sword
it's light saber ma thanks the good
folks at Hasbro hey man if you're
sitting at home and you're like we would
like to see you guys open this we'll
play with this or touch these weird
things money there's a way we can make
that happen all you have to do is write
to the screen jockeys over Twitter or on
our Facebook page
or so get in touch with the screen
jockeys email right here and they'll
totally put things in our hands that
will open up and you'll see men come
back next week and we'll take more
things out of boxes as we ask the
immortal question what's in the box what
what
[Music]
you
you